Sir, there is a ball thrown vertically down, word, a ball is
thrown vertically down, word, with velocity 20,
okay, there is a tower, thrown from top to downwards, from
whom did you throw it, sir, at 20 meters second,
saying OK, it hits the ground
after some time with velocity 80  When it was going to hit,
its velocity became
80. Okay, height of the tower is asking. Height
of the tower is asking. Now let me
tell you, I can also do it from work energy theorem -
10 should be taken in all.  It
was here also -80's squa, here also -20
's squa and here also -10 should have been taken
because Adarsh ​​sir has said brother,
all the things will be negative downwards and
s, this is here, I am fine sir, Bhavya, absolute.
Correct man, absolutely right Ishtiaq, absolutely
right, absolutely right, very good, so option number
C is absolutely correct answer here,
what is option number C here, absolutely correct answer, it
will be 300 meters downwards.